the arm guys over at the refuge are
saying the government needs to give them
back the land what do you say I think
it's hilarious because it was never
there like to begin with you know every
person that had to claim you know let
them have a voice whose land is it
anyway we the people of the United
States of America this is all our land
belong to the Indians they was here
first
they were here first the white man come
in autumn all 53% of Oregon is federal
land armed men occupying the Malheur
National Wildlife Refuge are demanding
the federal government transfer it to
local control for ranching mining and
logging meanwhile leaders of the Byrnes
Paiute Tribe say it's their ancestral
land and that the federal government is
managing it properly all this debate
over the land has brought me here to the
Byrnes Paiute native reservation I'm
here to ask the tribal member what she
thinks about it all well this is a home
I grew up in and and also the the
cradleboard that I was was put in did
you guys make these yeah what do you
make them out of windows and this willow
is this from the refuge where the
occupations taking place now correct the
timing of all this when you look at the
history is pretty crazy I read that 137
years ago this month your ancestors were
forced out of that same land where the
refuge is today the u.s. Calvary were
the ones that marched us off and shot
our people we were shot you know kill
those who are sick or fell behind
we're shot and left for dead you know a
lot of us didn't make it
ancestors of the burns Paiute once
roamed all of southeastern Oregon but
fierce battles over land were sparked
when settlers moved in in the 1870s
Paiutes and other tribes were forced
onto the Malheur reservation later under
pressure from settlers President Grant
opened up a portion of Malheur Lake to
the settlers the tribes revolted they
lost the war and were marched off the
reservation
to Washington State in 1908 with a
native bird population dwindling because
of overhunting President Theodore
Roosevelt made the area a Wildlife
Refuge in 1928 a land company gave the
landless burns Paiute ten acres of
former city dump the reservation has
since grown but only a third of the
tribes survived the land battles today
sarah tells me there's about 420 members
they tried to exterminate us but you
know what we're still here oh we are
victors we're survivors and we always
will be your tribal leaders have said
that these men are desecrating your
sacred sites on that they need to leave
do you agree I agree with my tribal
leaders there are a lot of
archaeological sites out there and
burials that you know they may not know
that they are disturbing do you think
any good has come from this whole
situation
I think it is too early to tell
I believe it just brought attention to
the in justices to the ranchers this
community and especially the burns play
each tribe and how they call it their
land and and really I believe it belongs
to new one and my beliefs are shipping
offenses boundary lines
you